الى ايران والاحتجاجات المستمره اذا تواصل
شرطه الايرانيه استخدام الاعدام كوسيله
لترهيب بهدف قمع حركه الاحتجاجات حيث كانت
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ان مح ان
محكمه الثوره في محافظه ايلام غرب ايران
اصدار الحكم بالاعدام ضد فتاه متظاهره
تدعى سوريا شريفه وتبلغ من العمر 16 عاما
وقالت المنظمه ان شريف اعتقل في نوفمبر
الماضي بعد مداهمه منزل جدتها
الضرب مشيره الى ان المحققين اجبروها على
الاعتراف بصنع زجاجات حارقه وكتابه
شعاراته
وفي ملف يعتقالات ايران التعسفيه لا تزال
ردود الفعل الدورى المندد تتواولى حيث
اعلنت عضوتان في البرلماني الالماني عن
تبنيهما الكفاله السياسيه للمحتجه شايان
جاراني الذي اتهمته ايران بالافساد في
الارض والمحتج المراهقه ايضا سوريا شريفي
البالغه من العمر 16 عاما فقط المحبوسين
في السجون الايرانيه والذين يواجهان خطر
الاعدام فيما اعلنت النائبه عن في
البرلمان السويدي
وكاله السياسيه المعارض للمعارضه
الايرانيه فارزنا قره المحكوم عليها
بالسجن لمده خمسه 25 عاما
الهولنديه مشاهدينا ايضا طرب بتجديد
العقوبات على النظام الايراني بسبب ما
وصفه بالقمع الوحشي ضد المحتاجين مطالبا
بفرض عقوبات على جميع نواب النظام وادراج
الحرس الثوري الايراني في قائمه الجماعات
الارهابيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي